[Music]
now I am tripping right now I think I
told him you'd lift they're just they
already did Yahoo yes add a reset when
you died right yeah I might be able to
help with that
I died 11 times I was stuck reliving the
same day over and over again into
someone wearing a baby mask ordered me
on the night of my birthday
turns out it was my roommate Laurie I
kicked her crazy ass out a window and
killed her which both to Luke but now
I'm living the better version of my life
[Applause]
okay okay yeah I thought of your pants
how to ended the loop but I'm back oh my
god everything's different this time
it's coming after all of us if you don't
be set the day and try again they're
dead for good aren't they so I'm gonna
have to die over and over again to save
all of you I mean I guess you could just
reset the day yourself genius idea I
don't stop because I want people will
die
failure is not an option
focus man my money on behind gotta be
let's see what you got
Green crisis mode tree who's gonna
pledge Kappa now that we have a death
curse
[Music]